IDO GREEN: Hello and welcome to
another episode of GDL-IL,
GDL Israel.
Today we're going to speak about
a few things that are
related to Google Cloud
platforms, HTML5, new
features, and new APIs that you
could leverage when you're
building a modern web
application or a modern mobile
web application.
So without further ado,
let's jump to the
slides that I prepared.
Some of them are based on my
talk in the last Google I/O
and I'll put links in the show
notes so you'll be able to
check them out.
So before jump into see how
we're building a modern web
app, let's put ourselves on
the same page and try to
define to ourselves what is
a modern web application.
A few of the main
characteristics that we see
now with all the modern web
applications that are good and
quality is that all of them
are self-contained.
All of them are coming with one
specific goal in mind and
they're trying to give the users
the best capability to
achieve their goal.
Most of the apps will be built
with offline first
methodologies, so exactly like
Eric Schmidt coined the term,
mobile first a few years back.
Today, we want to think about
those apps as offline first.
So very similar to what you see
today with native apps.
Those apps will have one
connection to the server.
Download the skeleton of the
app itself mainly the
structure of the JavaScript
HTML and CSS
that defined the app.
And later on the application
could make more connections to
bring data and be more useful.
As we're shifting more and more
logic to the client side
from the server side, we see a
flourishing in the MVC, MV*
Frameworks.
We want to avoid our spaghetti
code and we want to have a
clear separation between
our data and our views.
All the apps will
be device aware.
We have today devices that have
that two inch screen and
TVs they have 100 inch screen.
All of them have Chrome inside
or any other web browser and
we want the user to be able
to be productive.
It doesn't matter what is the
real estate of the screen that
she's working with.
So we need to think about when
we're designing the app and
then when we're building it so
it will do the best with the
limited real estate that each
and every device is allowing.
Parameters is a hash tag that
we're using during Google I/O
just to make it as important
as possible.
Users love apps that are
snappy and work fast.
And we want to make sure that
the web apps will work as fast
as possible with 60
frame per second.
Above it is of course waste
and below it the user will
make his life or her life
less attractive.
So why offline first?
There are very good reasons
down here but I would like
just to emphasize that
we want performance.
We want the app to work as fast
as the app or the user to
wait on an AJAX connection.
We want to make sure
that the app
returning as fast as possible.
And then doing in the background
the syncing and
making sure that we have the
knowledge and the data both on
the client and on the server.
Of course, it's very useful
when you have flaky
connections like in coffee
shops or on the
car or on the road.
And of course, in cases that you
don't have any connection
like a submarine
or an airplane.
In our demo that we'll show you
soon, we used Lawnchair.
And the main goal here or the
main outcome from this slide
is just to take into
consideration that you do want
to use some sort of
abstraction layer.
How to achieve offline?
Luckily, for us, today HTML5
is quite robust in terms of
the APIs that it allows us to
leverage when we come in to
achieve this goal.
So first we want to store the
assets and the basics skeleton
of the app and we'll do
that with AppCache.
And then we want to store data
so we have a simple key value
API which is local storage
web storage.
And for the ones that need the
full blown database on the
client side, they could
use IndexedDB which
is a new SQL database.
Or if you do want to use file,
like you're using in any other
platform, real files could be
text string files and it could
be binary files, just
use the File API.
The main challenge with offline
is that you do need to
pretend at the beginning that
there is no internet
connection so you have just
a skeleton of your app.
And then you want to do in the
background a very smart sync
layer that will know what data
the user needs now and what
data should be saved in
the one source of
truth the server side.
Here at the bottom, you could
see the one simple API that we
have today, which will allow
us to know when the user is
offline for sure, then we could
have assumption that the
user is online if the offline
return code is false.
How we're achieving AppCache
it's very, very simple.
We do need to define the
one manifest file,
like you see here.
And in this manifest file,
basically will define what is
the asset that we want to
leave on the client
side all the time.
So in this very simple example
you could see here that we are
caching the main JavaScript
file, some simple CSS that is
based on Twitter Bootstrap, and
one image, just a really
hello world example.
One thing that you do want to
keep in mind is that if this
file is changed, the browser
will be smart enough to go to
the server and download
a new version.
So you never ever want to cache
the manifest itself
because you won't be able to
upgrade your app which is
definitely not something
you want to do.
Another thing here is to
have this comment.
So usually any change in this
file will force the browser to
make another connection and
fetch a new version.
And one easy way to control this
is just by making sure
that your build tool is changing
this one line and
just increasing the version.
As you can see here with the
link I use dot com, AppCache
is quite popular in all the
different mobile web browsers
supporting it.
So you could definitely
leverage it.
It will work when the user
is online as well.
So you're achieving the boost in
performance because assets
that are already there on the
client side are not making any
network connection.
So if you have a few images or
an icon for your app, you
don't need to go and fetch it
from the server after the
first download.
In terms of storage APIs today,
here you can see the
lay of the land and we do have
local storage, as I said, on
all the different
mobile browsers.
With Web SQL and IndexedDB we
have a bit of an issue because
as you can see, Web SQL is
supported on all the different
platforms, but IndexedDB is so
far not supported on iOS.
So when you do want to work with
a full blown database on
the client side, you do want
to check one of the
abstraction layers here, just to
make sure that you are more
productive.
The IndexedDB scheme basically
will let you work with the Web
SQL and IndexedDB
in the same way.
And you could search later on
my blog I wrote a blog post
that let's you transfer
your Web SQL code
to IndexedDB code.
The main reason is
that Web SQL is a
deprecated API from 2010.
So as you all know, as the best
practice says not to work
with a deprecated API that won't
be develop maintain.
And you do want to move to an
API that is supported by the
W3C and the browser vendors.
And that's why we highly
recommend to move and work
with IndexedDB.
Not to mention that IndexedDB
by default is working with
JSON objects so it's much
simpler to work with your
JavaScript code of course.
Let's speak briefly about
designing modern web
applications.
The new way to do it is quite
different from the old one in
the sense that we don't have
today this long, wonderful
process of let's ship the design
to the designer, they
will dream things in their
Photoshop, giving us the PSD.
We'll need the process to break
it down to HTML and CSS,
and then show them
what we did.
Then they're returning to us
with answers that we did a
horrible job et cetera,
et cetera.
Today, most of the startups and
other companies people are
trying to move as fast
as possible.
And the right way to think about
agile programming and
agile methodology is to have the
initial design or really
the white frames and the main
framework of all the
[INAUDIBLE]
work and do already coding
in HTML and text.
So have some sketch.
The main building blocks
are there.
You could use Balsamiq.
You could do lots of different
modern apps that are in Chrome
Web Store that will help
you achieve this
crude design phase.
And then, quite quickly, you
could move on and do a more
thorough sketch by just adding
a layer of the CSS, so making
it a bit prettier.
So it's not just blocks now.
It's maybe blocks with some
color and some shape.
So it's letting us grasp and
see how it will work.
Then we want some sort of a
prototype and we'll use it, or
we'll add the layer of
the JavaScript with
our logic in it.
And then the other is just-- and
that's actually the main
phase that you could see, the
major difference between
professionals and amateurs that
polish phase could be
tiny, could be a very long
and thorough one.
But in that phase you could
actually see if the app is
going to be a really
shine one or not.
And I'm speaking just about the
user experience right now.
Then, of course, it's trivial
to want to do some real
thorough testing, maybe use a
real device lab just to make
sure that the app is working
on the targeted devices.
And then production
and iterating more
and more and more.
When we approaching it, we do
want to think about the web
apps and the mobile web apps
as full-blown applications.
So it's quite different from
the old days-- and speaking
just about 13 months back
or something like that--
it's not pages anymore.
And you do need to take it into
consideration and make
sure that you're designing from
bottom up and not just
trying to put some nice colors
and some nice shiny bottom on
top of the current app.
It will be much harder
to achieve it.
Another way to achieve large
scale apps is just to think or
to break the problem to
different models, different
components, and in the near
future we'll see a huge
improvement in terms of web
components that the platform,
the web itself is going
to support.
We'll do some more talks in the
future, in the near future
in GDL-IL and in GDL enlarge.
And I highly encourage you to
check it out because it's one
of those revolutions that's
starting right now.
You will be able to take web
components or to use
components in your web app.
It will make two things.
One, there will be ecosystem
so developers could sell
components.
And another great benefit is
that every component in your
app will be encapsulated.
So we are achieving here the
holy grail of encapsulation
and that's of course a great
thing, a great benefit that
you don't need to
repeat yourself.
And achieve lots of great
benefits in terms of
maintaining, scaling, testing,
and just making sure that you
are able to build large
apps with really
solid building blocks.
Less is more.
In lots of those apps, if you
remember, we're trying to aim
or to achieve one
specific goal.
So it's very different from
the portals of the old way
that we had on sites that
you're trying to achieve
everything and then you
achieve nothing.
Here, if your app is taking
photos, do just that.
Try to do it the best you can,
but do just one specific goal.
When we're speaking about using
and reusing code and
things, that most important
thing is to try not to
reinvent the wheel and invest
lots of time and effort on
some problem that is already
solved, or someone built a
library that solved it.
Here, I'm just [INAUDIBLE] to
check out when you're thinking
about your next project.
And please don't let Web or
Enterprise be an excuse for
poor design and poor UX and
a poor user experience.
When you are making your design
phase, try to think
about forms, tablets, or just
the same form of devices.
So if you have a phone and a
tablet that are both within
aspect ratio of four by three
or 16 by 9, probably it's a
good corner to cut.
And make sure that your design
is supporting those two
screens in the same way.
It will make your life easier
and actually the user
won't notice it.
Here in the example you could
see Flipboard that having two
different approaches to their
tablet app and the mobile app.
By the way, they didn't even
use the memory muscles that
user gained from the
tablet experience.
And on the phone, they just
decided that the flip will be
vertical and not horizontal
because it's a better user
experience.
When we're speaking about the
unknown and different screen
sizes, you do want to adapt to
the adaptive app philosophy.
Since it's really hard to just
encapsulate everything that
you think about in the dome, you
do want to make sure that
the app itself will be
responsive in the sense that
it will do the best within
the same form factor.
It could be four three
and it could be 16 9.
And you don't want to use
progressive enhancement.
One of the main benefits
of the web is that it's
everywhere and even smartphones
that are not so
smart contain some sort
of a web browser.
So the most basic capabilities
should be achieved with the
minimum requirement.
And then on top of that, if
you're getting really new
shiny phone that have quad core
and lots of capabilities
and supporting many HTML5 APIs,
yeah, progress on it,
give it a better user
experience.
But make sure that the users are
able to do something with
your app even if they don't have
the greatest and latest
in terms of their web browser.
A great example is Gmail.
If your connection is really
slow or the web browser is not
supported, you will be
downgraded to an HTML version
that lets you be productive.
But it's definitely nothing to
compare with the full blown
Gmail that will work on Chrome,
definitely, if you're
working with the offline
Gmail capabilities from
the Chrome Web Store.
When we come to build a web
application, there are few
things that we need to think
about and just keep working
and polished.
So one is, of course, the basic
fundamental separation
between our data
and our views.
That's one of the main reason
that we see many different
frameworks out there that are
coming to solve this problem
and making our life more, let's
say, painless or more
beneficial in terms
of productiveness.
It's not just the separation.
It's coming to tackle a few
things that developers are
tackling again and again, like
two-way data bending, like
dependency injection, testing
capabilities, and the way to
hold in your code the state
and the data of your user.
One of my favorite client
side framework
these days is AngularJS.
AngularJS is one of those
open source projects
that started in Google.
I found it to be really useful
and lots of people are using
it, both internally
and externally.
And lucky for us webfront
developers at large, it's an
open source project now.
And what I do like in this
framework is that it took a
very different approach
from all the other
frameworks out there.
Those smart guys that came with
a heavy Java background
decided to bake dependency
injection and testable
capabilities in the framework
from day one.
And it's one of those power
features that really make you
more productive, specifically
where the apps is growing
quite fast.
It also has two-way
data binding.
And one of the beauty things
that I really like is that
it's basically looking at HTML
and just making it dynamic.
Other great things that I highly
encourage you to check
out is the directives in Angular
that basically is a
web component of the future,
but today in Angular.
So you could be really
productive by encapsulating
your code, making a directive,
and then use it, and reuse it
again and again.
When we're speaking about the
mobile world today and the
flourishing of mobile devices,
in most of the cases if you
built on your server some strong
API, you will want to
consume it from different
devices, different browsers,
and different platforms.
And it's one way to just use
with the RESTful API from your
mobile or web app, and another
way just to use it from your
native iOS or native
Android app.
With that, we're just going to
Cloud endpoints and why it's
extremely good for you.
We always have this long, long
way to achieve our great app
and our great unique knowledge
by dealing with a server.
And server is not
an easy problem.
And usually you need to think
about lots of things and scale
it on your own and making sure
that you are being able to
handle with huge amount of logs
and sharing sharding and
lots of pain points.
And in the end of the day, even
if you're starting with a
simple API at the beginning,
quite quickly you see that you
need to deal with a spike in
traffic that's making things
even more hard.
And you do want to have some
sort of communication or
authentication, serialization,
and not to mention search and
other APIs if you want to use
over again and again.
Luckily for us, I won't touch
on it too deeply, but with
Google App Engine, platform
is a service.
We have all those things being
taken care of for us and
that's being taken care of for
us by the top experts in the
world, lots of different high
scale app like Khan Academy,
Pulse, and others are hosted
on App Engine.
And App Engine has the
automating scanning and lots
of other benefits for you.
We have App Engine technology
supporting today Java, Go,
Python, and PHP.
And the main thing here is
that for us, front end
developers, I just pointed the
arrow here on the right, you
want to focus on what you're
bringing to the table, and not
tackling with the usual
administrative stuff that you
do want someone else to
take care of for you.
With Cloud Endpoints the
beauty is that you're
basically sitting on top Google
App Engine, but with a
certain or unique interface that
lets you later on consume
your API from any platform.
It could be Android.
It could be iOS.
It could be the web.
Let's just got back up for one
second, the truck, and see
what we're talking about.
Basically, we're having Google
API as a discovery API.
And in this discovery API, you
could see this JSON format
that lets you understand what
the API itself is doing and
how you could tap into
it and leverage it.
In our short example, it's the
UR: shorter and you can see
here that you have the
full description.
And as a developer, you could
come, consume it, and then use
it quite quickly.
The benefit with Google Cloud
Endpoint is that you could
have this discovery document
for your needs.
So if you're working in a
company that has a front end
team and a back end team, this
discovery document that Google
lets you have and leverage,
could be the one point that
those two teams are
interacting.
And this is one way to just
work more productively.
Luckily for us, we have many
client libraries that already
contain those APIs and making
your life easier.
So I won't touch about the
service side, but you could
imagine that there are even more
libraries than the ones
that I choose to mention here.
On the mobile, we're having a
very nice coverage with all
the main platforms out there.
And of course, for the web, we
have it with JavaScript for
node and for Dart.
Just to see how simple it is, so
basically what you need to
do is just load with this one
called the Google API client
and giving it a callback.
Once you've given it a callback
in the init, will
come here, and then we could
load the shorter API, the ads
API, map API, any API that you
want you could just specify
the version if your application
is supporting a
specific version.
And of course, giving it here
another callback so you could
start running and doing
interesting stuff
with the API itself.
So what we saw here is that it's
basically giving you the
one ability to just focus on
what you're doing good and
what you are excelling
at and then
consuming from any platform.
Let's have a quick look about
how simple it is to work with
our app that will built.
And we built an app that
is called Pictures.
We'll do it in a second
and I'll show you a
live demo of the app.
But here you can see how
easy it is to get a
photo from the app.
So we'll have this GET request
with the photo and the ID.
And here we're getting
the response back.
So we're getting the photo
encoded in 64 base, and all
the metadata that we
have on this photo.
An insert.
An insert on the data
on the server side.
Here is the shortest Python
example that we gave you.
How easy it is to work with
the Python version.
But for the ones that are
passionate about Python and
want to see more how you
leverage and built Cloud
Endpoint with Python, we'll have
a full show in the near
future that will just focus
on the server side.
On the client side, you can see
here that in our drag and
drop example, we're going and
when the user is clicking on
the Save button, we're just
going online three to five and
just fetching all the attributes
from our phone,
having a simple short case on
line seven for the photo
itself because it's
a bit trickier.
And then we're just going and
call Google API with our own
unique API that we created,
which is called Pictures.
And just calling photo.insert
with the payload features.
Then what we need to
do is just execute
it and have a callback.
As you can see here in the
callback, we just want to make
sure that everything is done
properly and give the user the
notification that the photo
has been saved.
Or if something went wrong and
we have 400 or any other error
code, we want to confirm it and
notify the user about it.
The update example will
be exactly the same.
We just use the endpoint
of [INAUDIBLE].
So it's quite sweet.
And for the ones that are saying
now, hey, come on, it's
not very efficient.
You change, let's say, the name
and you've given me all
the upload again, we do have the
endpoint of patch which is
giving you the ability just to
give the server the deltas
that you've changed.
So we saw the most basic
crude operation.
And to get at list of out
photos, it's very simple here.
You can see, I'm just calling
the list and then I'm
executing and going on
the item itself.
And of course, add photos
could do something
interesting for us.
Let's jump to the demo.
And let me just show you
how the app is working.
So I'll share my screen.
Hopefully, the right one.
Let's see that I'm sharing.
Yes.
OK.
So this is the screen and I'll
put the show notes recording
of this demo that we did on
a live mobile device.
But for now, just to show
you quickly how the
app itself is working.
So as you can see, we have
here the ready button.
And for now, I won't disconnect
the network because
I'm doing a Hangout and we do
need the network, but if you
want later on to go to Pictures
App on [INAUDIBLE]
and play with the app you'll
yourself, you'll be able to
see that if you are after, of
course, you're downloading the
app and working with it, you are
disconnecting your machine
from the network.
This button will change its
color from green to red and it
will be written here offline.
So you'll know that you
are now offline.
But everything should work.
Right now we are online and
let's say that enough I see my
amazing photos that
I already took.
Let's try and add a new photo.
So I'm taking a photo.
In our case, it's just
opening in our file.
And I'll try and we
have your QR code.
I'll give it a title
and description.
And I'm saving it.
Now notice when I'm clicking
on Save, we getting a
confirmation that the QR picture
was saved locally
quite quickly.
Because we save it in the
local storage very fast.
And now you could see that
we're getting another
confirmation that the photo
was sent and been
saved in the Cloud.
They beauty here is that
you [INAUDIBLE]
and we did it, of course, the
two face commit here just for
the demo purposes.
But to show you, the developers,
how quickly it was
to save it locally, to making
sure that we're doing the
right thing, and the user, even
if he doesn't have any
connection or very flaky
connection, the responsiveness
is immediate and the user
gets something quickly.
The other side of things is
that we do want this one
source of true and we do want
to share the information in
the server.
So from each and every device
that the user will go later
on, she would be able to
download and see all the
photos, and that's what
made it very nice.
So we have one source of true,
but then we're saving it
locally as well quickly.
Let me show here one of
the beauties of the
web platform today.
If I'm opening DEV tool here by
right clicking and inspect
element on the take photo item,
you could see here--
and let me make it
much larger--
you see here I wrote the comment
the magic is here.
Basically, this one line, not
the label, sorry, the input--
the label is just to make
the button nicer.
And that's one hack that you'll
need to do if you want
such a nice button and not the
default one that the browsers
are now giving you and
it's not so sexy.
But the nice here is that the
platform itself letting you
today have this input field.
And once you've put in the
[INAUDIBLE] except image,
capture camera, if you run it on
a mobile web browser, let's
say a Nexus 4 or any modern
Android device, or iPhone, you
will get the ability to take a
photo now from the camera, or
to choose a photo that you
already saved on your mobile
device without PhoneGap, without
any other external
source that you need
to compile or to
bake into your app.
So we see clearly that the web
platform and mobile browsers
are running fast into
the right direction.
And that's basically letting you
now, of course, that I'm
not in a mobile environment just
do the right thing and
just to choose a file.
So let's choose quickly
another file.
Not a very good one.
Conversation, conversation,
let's save it.
Again, you could see that you
put in the right place.
And it will give me another
confirmation once it's being
saved in the server side.
Of course, we have some nice
capabilities to do sharing
with G+ API, but I guess we'll
touch on them on the next
episode because I see that quite
quickly we're running
out of time.
Just jump really quick to the
main takeaway from the talk.
Basically, what we wanted to
show you is that it's a really
powerful solution to build
your next API and then
services on Google
Cloud Endpoints.
And we highly encourage
you to check it out.
Other great aspect today to
front end developers, it's
HTML5 APIs and the readiness of
the mobile web to give more
and more capabilities and
ability to be close to the
device and close to
the metal to the
developer and to the user.
So things like [INAUDIBLE]
API, rotation, orientation,
accelerometer, Blue Tooth, et
cetera, are being baked into
the platform quite quickly.
Some of them are
already there.
And AngularJS is one framework
that lets you be more
productive.
And it contains some of the cool
aspects like directives
that are basically what web
components will look in the
near future.
And in mobile web browsers, you
should leverage new cool
things that are going to be
there quite quickly, like Web
RTC, multi-threads in Web
Workers, and flourishing
movement in CSS 3, layouts
and other great benefits.
So thank you very much
for your time.
If you have any questions,
please feel free
to ping me on G+.
You could find me here
or on Twitter.
The code for the app itself will
be on GitHub, actually
it's right there on GitHub right
now and you are most
welcome to take it.
And the slides will be later
on ido-green@appsspot.com.
So let's see if we have any
questions right now.
I see that we don't.
So until next time, thank you
very much and bye bye.